so
yes
happy monday
[Music]
[Music]
okay
what you believe becomes
your reality you can make
a difference you are strong
[Music]
you got this you're okay
you're okay you are okay you're
you're rocky you rock
a you
are on the right path
you are left
you are so left
you deserve all of the love
and all of the happiness
things will change for the better
it will get better this
too shall pass
you are not ugly
you are just not your type
drink your coffee or your tea
stay focused find the inspiration
don't freak out
you got this and remember
stabbing people is wrong excuses
will always be there
but opportunities won't and that's
a fact you are never too old
to set a new goal or go
after a new dream
you're just not you're beautiful
you're strong you're fearless
fear does not control you
take a moment and
unfuck your thoughts
what we dwell on is what we become
you can make it happen if anybody can do
it
if i a human being can do it
you can definitely do it
let those knows let those rejections
motivate you towards success
love yourself
how you love others
who is the most awesome person today
you are
fear kills more dreams
than failure ever will
life is stuff but
so are you
stay positive
today is going to be awesome
go out there and show them what you're
made of
chase what you're passionate about
do what you love
work hard
life is beautiful
life is beautiful if you let it
your perspective is your reality
if you believe it you can achieve it
i love you
i think that's all for today
think happy thoughts and you
love that